let's go to susan now it says susan from
la is that los angeles is that louisiana
from los angeles susan from los angeles
what's going on
oh um what did you um
i was trying to connect yesterday but
i was wondering about the um
how the mcconnell i think it was
mcconnell
they're now supporting trump
yeah i mean mcconnell's playing i mean
listen
yes mcconnell's disgusting and toxic
obviously
mcconnell's kind of playing it a little
bit coy by saying
the president is entitled to all of the
legal recourse
and to demand recounts and everything i
mean i'm wondering
after it's certified i'm wondering what
happens after the certification
if republicans will still keep kind of
playing dumb
my guess is a lot of them after the
certification on december 14th
we'll st will start just saying joe
biden is the president
but for the time being very few of them
are straight up just saying
yeah biden won and he's the
president-elect and it's pretty vile
and what's kind of um oh
frustrating yet it might be good
it's like the republicans at least
they're fight you know we didn't fight
for gore
enough and how we conceded so early
yeah i mean to a humiliating degree
republicans are just continuing
continuing continuing and you can say
that that's virtuous or that that
it's humiliating i guess it depends on
the situation but
obviously i would have liked to have
seen democrats fight more in 2016 with
merrick garland
with amy coney barrett but this is the
situation as it stands today
yeah listen susan what part of la are
you in
i'm right by the airport really yeah
i can hear the plane explain it i love
it it's called westchester
west chester like in new york's
westchester yeah
yeah love it all right susan i hope to
be back in la once it's all
settled down you know that'll be great
yeah
all right susan thank you so much we're
going to take a quick break but if
you're holding on to talk to me please
don't hang up don't hang up my friends
because i'm going to be going back to
the phones momentarily
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video